-Thank you, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching. [ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much for tuning in.
Guys, let's get to some news.
Today, President Biden held a meeting at the White House
with Israeli President Isaac Herzog.
Biden and Israel's president spent hours together.
They discussed Iran, Russia,
and all of their favorite tracks off the new Taylor Swift album.
[ Laughter ]
"Lavender Haze."
Meanwhile, earlier today, President Biden also announced
a plan to cut hidden bank and credit-card fees
in an effort to give families more breathing room.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ] Good.
More breathing room. Interesting. Yeah.
"Breathing room" sounds like
Biden's launching his own line of Skims.
To be honest, I don't know if Biden
is the best person to talk about giving people breathing room.
But I don't know. Maybe I'm wrong. I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Biden also said that he's looking to get rid of
added fees on cable bills.
That's great news.
[ Cheers and applause ] That's great news.
Great news for the three people who still have cable.
It's amazing news.
Some more news -- Russia just notified the U.S.
that they would be launching nuclear-capable missiles
as part of their annual nuclear exercise.
Russia is just like us --
they also exercise only once a year.
It's great.
But the U.S. is keeping a close eye on Russia.
Yesterday, Biden said that it would be
a "serious, serious mistake"
for Russia to use nuclear weapons.
Wow. I haven't heard words that powerful
since FDR called Japan's attack on Pearl Harbor
a "major no-no." [ Laughter ]
That's right. Biden said that if Russia uses nuclear weapons
they would be making a "serious, serious mistake."
Yep. And he didn't stop there.
Next he said, "For realsies, you better not."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-No. He went on. -Oh.
[ Applause ]
-"For realsies." -Yeah.
-He went on to say, "But if you wanna really be real,
I'm actually on BeReal.
Just search POTUS and check it out."
And finally, he said, "But seriously, no cap fam.
This behavior is making me salty. Don't @ me."
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is he talk-- I don't know what he's doing.
Guys, I want to say happy birthday to Hillary Clinton,
who turned 75 today.
[ Applause ]
Hillary Clinton.
Of course, Hillary got a lot of texts for her birthday,
and we actually got ahold of some of them.
Yeah, for instance, Ron DeSantis texted...
Next, Vladimir Putin texted...
Then Adidas texted...
"We're giving them away. Free."
Next up, Donald Trump texted...
Bernie Sanders texted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[As Sanders] Send!
[ Applause ]
Next up, Bill Clinton texted...
That's nice.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Joe Biden texted...
"Send!"
[ Applause ]
Nice of everyone to reach out, don't you think?
That's right. Today is Hillary Clinton's 75th birthday.
But I looked it up, and it turns out October 26th
is a lot of people's birthday,
so it's only fair that I wish them all a happy birthday.
This should only take a second.
Feel free to sing along if you want.
[ Clears throat ]
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, dear Hillary Clinton ♪
♪ And Keith Urban ♪
♪ And Seth MacFarlane ♪
♪ And Pat Sajak ♪
♪ And John Heder, a.k.a. Napoleon Dynamite ♪
♪ And Rita Wilson ♪
♪ And Dylan McDermott ♪
♪ And Jaclyn Smith ♪
[ Clock ticking ]
[ Laughter ]
♪ And Bootsy Collins ♪
♪ And Schoolboy Q ♪
♪ And my childhood babysitter, Tiffany O'Brien ♪
[ Clock ticking ]
♪ And professional wrestler C.M. Punk ♪
♪ And former Kenyan President Uhuru Kenyatta ♪
Oh, forget it. I can't do everybody.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, you forgot to mention
that today is my birthday, Jimmy.
-Well, we got a lot of jokes to tell.
Guys --
[ Audience awws ]
Some business -- Some business news.
Today TJ Maxx announced
that they were cutting ties with Kanye West
and no longer selling any of his Yeezy merchandise.
And -- And I personally think I had a small part in that.
Here's a joke that we did from the monologue last night.
This is real.
And now GAP also announced
that they're pulling all Yeezy products from their stores.
-Oh. Meanwhile, TJ Maxx is like,
"We'll sell whatever ya got.
We let it rip in this place."
Thank you for watching, TJ Maxx.
We love you guys.
-You're a Maxxanista. -Yeah.
Get this, everyone.
Snoop Dogg's professional blunt roller
just revealed that Snoop smokes up to 150 blunts a day.
You know, I'm worried
because if this keeps up, he might form a habit.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I heard about a documentary
about Ed Sheeran in the works. I love Ed Sheeran.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It sounds cool, but I'm not sure the producers
really did their research.
Take a look at the promo they released.
-We're excited to announce a documentary
about one of the world's biggest music stars, Ed Sheeran.
We'll dive into Ed Sheeran's life,
his dedication to music, his hobbies and interests,
and we'll look at never-before-seen photos
of the legendary musician at home and on the road.
"The Ed Sheeran Documentary." Don't miss it.
-You see what I mean? I just feel like --
I feel like they didn't do their homework.
[ Applause ]
Hey, I saw that the new horror series "The Watcher"
is the number-one show on Netflix
for the second week in a row.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Over 270 million hours viewed since its release.
-Wait. Did you say "The Watcher"?
-Yeah. Why? -Well, that's what the guy
who wrote us that letter called himself.
-What letter? -This one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Dearest neighbor at Studio 6B,
allow me to welcome you to the building.
I've been put in charge of watching you.
This message will not be the last.
Your studio is my obsession, and now you are, too.
Who am I? I am the Watcher.
I will never stop watching."
[ Eerie music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
That's so nice of you!
-[ Giggles ] Thanks, Jimmy. I'm a really big fan.
-Oh, nice to see you.
[ Applause ]
He watches. He watches the show.
-That's the Watcher. -Here you go.
-Thank you. Yeah, throw the letter back.
-No problem.
-Oh. Got it. -Yeah. I got it. No problem.
Some more, uh...
[ Applause ]
Some more entertainment news. Next week, "Jeopardy!"
is bringing back its "Tournament of Champions" where --
I love it.
Where the year's best contestants
face off against each other.
Yeah, I saw a commercial for it last night.
It doesn't look like they picked
the best of the best for it, though.
I don't know. You guys be the judge.
-This is "Jeopardy!'s Tournament of Champions."
-Elizabeth. -What is "Fight Club"?
-No.
Suzanne. -Who is Billy Crystal?
Here is a pair of wireless these with a friendly name.
Fernando. -What are plants?
-No. Chris?
-What is cheddar cheese? -No.
Tory. -Who are the Wright Brothers?
-No.
Rhiannon. -What is "Cake Boss"?
-What's a dab? -No.
-Ah. Interesting.
Right? That's interesting.
Well, this is going viral.
An antique furniture gallery showed off a rare
19th-century Italian desk. This is real.
An Italian desk. And it's got a lot of storage space.
Look at this thing.
-First we have here is you press a button,
and the writing slope comes out.
Then, on the sides, you press one of the buttons,
and a secret drawer comes out.
You press another button on the inside,
and secret drawers come out on the end.
Press a button on the side, the lion heads come out.
And then you press a button further here,
and two more drawers come out.
Another drawer at the top.
Press a button, more drawers.
And then you press another button, and another one.
And here's the centerpiece for this one,
where you open it up, the drawers come out.
Of course, these are secret.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
That's when you know you got a weed problem.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Update on the story -- Snoop Dogg just moved to Italy.
-Are you serious? -Yep.
The desk also comes with a placard that says...
Well, there's a lot of bad things going on in the news right now,
but it looks like they solved at least one pressing issue.
Watch this. -We'll, you've heard about
horseshoes, but what about horse sneakers?
A new company called Horse Kicks
is now selling high-end sneakers made just for horses.
You'll find lots of the major brands,
like New Balance and Nike Air Jordans.
You can even get your horse sneakers to match your own.
-They have horse sneakers from Nike, New Balance,
and even those gross toe shoes
that everyone's embarrassed to wear in public.
They don't wear them in public. Only at home.
And finally, Costco is selling
the world's largest jigsaw puzzle.
It's 29 feet long, 8 feet tall, and 60,000 pieces.
Yeah, the bottom left corner goes on your coffee table.
The bottom right goes in Zimbabwe.
And a helpful hint. Here's what I did.
Start by taking seven or eight days to find the corner pieces.
Yeah. We have a great show, everyone.